now have you been listening to this show
for any time at all you have heard my
investment advice which is roundly
criticized by supposed experts out there
although I've made more millionaires in
America than just about anyone with this
horrible advice of mine but one piece of
advice is is that I don't invest in
anything I don't understand and I
recommend you don't do the same that you
do the same rather that you don't invest
in something unless you understand it
the second thing is is that I personally
buy and that's also what I recommend
good growth stock mutual funds and I buy
real estate that I pay cash for and
that's all I invest in other than my
business that's all I put money in and
the number of single stocks that I own I
don't invest in single stocks the number
of single stocks that I own is zero it's
too much risk although the mutual funds
have stocks in them there's ninety to
200 different ones and so your risk is
spread out in the financial world we
call that diversified you're not got all
your money in one thing because you put
your money in one single company you are
taking an inordinate amount of risk so
Wall Street Journal has an interesting
article and it's a very long article you
might want to look it up if you're
interested in this subject but it's a
very sad story of exactly why I tell
people not to do this
here's the story Gary is a Brosky
started working for General Electric in
1976 at an Aviation Factory in his
hometown of Lynn Massachusetts the job
paid well came with benefits and for mr.
zabrowski provided a career ladder for a
man with a high school education who
started out cleaning toilets you had a
job for life if you get in there said
mr. Zebrowski 61 years old he rose to
punch press operator and retired in 2016
after working 40 years at the
century-old plant
he left GE with an annual pension of
$85,000 Wow and company stock value
more than 280,000 retirement looked
pretty good until GE shares collapsed
all of his 280,000 was in General
Electric stock by the way his shares are
now worth about a hundred and ten
thousand prompting a late-life job hunt
I never planned on retiring and having
to go back to work said mr. Zebrowski
who has a monthly mortgage payment and
supports a partially disabled wife it's
kind of scary the rapid unraveling of GE
has wiped out roughly a hundred and
forty billion dollars in stock market
wealth in the past year not just at big
Wall Street firms but small investors
like mr. Zebrowski industrial giant is
one of the most widely held US stocks by
comparison the stock value lost by GE in
the past twelve months is twice the
amount that vanished when Enron
collapsed in 2001 and more than the
combined market capitalization erased by
the bankruptcies of Lehman Brothers and
General Motors during the financial
crisis longer term GES market cap has
fallen more than 460 billion since its
2000 peak this is not a segment where
Dave Ramsey picks it on General Electric
that is not what this is about
and by the way let's do a little bit of
quick math here mr. zabrowski started
with 280,000 now he has a hundred and
ten thousand he did not lose all his
money he lost half of it just a touch
over half of it but he did not lose all
his money so what what is the problem
here there's two problems in this number
one problem is is that he had all of his
retirement nest egg in one single stock
and nowhere in the process did he learn
being the owner of almost three hundred
thousand dollars that that was a bad
idea
had that been diversified I own mutual
funds that owned General Electric
and their value was affected in a
negative way by the fact that those at
General Electric stock is in there but
it didn't affect me by half it affected
me a tiny tiny bit and the other stocks
and the mutual funds went up more than
General Electric went down and so
actually the net effect was that my
mutual funds made money even though they
owned General Electric in there that's
the power of diversification spreading
out your investments lowers your risk he
basically went to the racetrack and took
two hundred eighty thousand dollars and
placed a bet on one horse and that horse
came up lame that's what this is that's
what you do when you play single stocks
you're asking for trouble well my broker
I don't want to hear about your broker
and I don't hear about you bragging on
the golf course on your fishing story
either because that's what stock trading
is it's fishing stories the one time it
went up for the 16 times you lost your
butt because it's too much risk and it's
certainly too much risk for mr.
Zebrowski now here's an interesting part
of this he's 61 years old they can't
live on eighty five thousand dollars a
year really okay
probably something else needs to be
adjusted in mr. Zebrowski life because
if his if it stock became worth zero he
has a pension of eighty five thousand
dollars a year so probably needs some
other stuff there going on right so he
had to go back to work because he can't
live on eighty five because his stock
but when I you went down that means he
was using that stock to live off because
he wasn't living off his $85,000 your
pension plus he's probably getting full
Social Security so he's probably getting
another fifteen thousand this guy's got
a hundred thousand dollar-a-year income
in retirement at sixty one years old so
I think we've got budget problems here
more than just this stock going down but
it does provide a cautionary tale Etta
ladies work for Procter & Gamble that I
counseled with about twenty years ago
and I remember the same thing she had
seven hundred thousand and it went down
to about three hundred and she said I've
lost all my money ins no you didn't lose
all your money but you did lose half of
it and it's a real problem I mean so and
you know still have that income produced
by seven hundred thousand you're gonna
get half the income you know produced by
three hundred fifty thousand give or
take right and so this is the problem
when you work for a company and you put
all of your net worth in or a large
portion of your net worth in that
company's company stock because you
quote-unquote believe in the company it
is good to be loyal to the company that
pays you
loyalty however does not require you
invest in their stock and so I don't buy
single stocks and oh by the way by the
time you're sixty one you ought to
figure out a way to live on a hundred
thousand dollars a year sometime during
your life you ought to get there
these are two things that we can take
from this story it's a long story and
it's worth reading the whole story I
don't get into the whole thing but this
is uh this is kind of how it comes down
very last line is the way GE stock is
going we might as well lose it all
what no you sell one hundred and ten
before you do lose at all